This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his
last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we explore the psychology of our 20s. Of course, it is guest month, December month, and we have an amazing guest, a homegrown Aussie guest here with us today. You may know her from her incredible podcast. Do You fucking mind? Alexis. Ferdness, how are you going? I'm so excited to be here.
It was, it's like two worlds colliding. It is two worlds colliding. I was like, this had to happen, right? I know. It was inevitable. I don't know how we've never spoken before. How? And we've just been sitting here now for like, I don't know how long.
Just like, we can't stop talking. Literally before we started recording, we were like having a discussion around zombie apocalyps. I don't know. How do we even get to that? Fire safety hazards and dead bolts on doors. Yeah. Not really relevant to psychology or self-care.
No. nonetheless was fulfilling for me. It was, I know. We've come up with some ideas to, you know, message our landlords. Yeah. Yes. Thank you. Thank you for that.
So I think it's so something that I don't even think I said this to you, but when I was in university, I was, I was a do you fucking mind stand? Really amazing. I still listen to it now, obviously, but I remember going through like my first huge breakup when I was 19, 18 years old. Yeah. And listening to your episodes on these like nature walks through camera. Oh my God.
I love that. Being like, heal me. That is the best. I know. I love that. It's a full circle moment for me. Yeah, this is amazing. And I feel like, I don't know, I feel like most of the people that were like the OGs who
have like shared the podcast and listened to it, it's they found me at a time of like deepest heartbreak, which is really, really cool. And then they've like gone on that journey. of like self-discovery and, you know, learning. I feel like you learn so much about yourself when you're heartbroken. It's like the biggest learning curve. It's pretty. And now I feel that when people are like, I've never been heartbroken,
I'm like, I'm a little bit sorry for you because it's such, I don't know, it's such a rich experience. I used to say like heartbreak is sacred. Isn't it? Because it's exactly as you said, people, I think, enter into a lot of like personal development and self-growth through heartbreak. And then they're suddenly like awoken to this whole. bigger spectrum of other things that are going to improve their life.
But they wouldn't have accessed if that, like, loser hadn't, you know, cheated on them or, like, rejected them. So you need to go through that pain. You need to go through something just not being fair. And how do you deal with that? Like, how do you, I think before you've experienced that, you've never experienced truly an unfair situation where there's no sense that can be made from it. Like, how do you move forward from something that can't be fixed and can't be made sense of?
And that's where you learn so much about, like, your resilience and how you make peace with something just yourself and not find closure and not, you know. My God, the closure thing I was talking to a friend of mine the other day. And she was like, how am I meant to move on when I can't stop thinking about this person? Oh, yeah. And I was like, you need to provide your own emotional closure in this moment. 100%. I don't know. So we're not even talking about heartbreak.
We may as well be. I love that this. We just get straight into the pepso. We just get straight into it. It's like immediately like, what are we here for? Inspiration. But what we are really here to talk about today is a topic that I think is so important during this season of the year.
Dealing with difficult family members, complex family dynamics. I don't love the word toxic, but I do think it applies here. It does. To certain families, it definitely would. Because I feel like what we were discussing before with some families, there's a lot of issues. but it's not necessarily toxic. It's just clashing of the minds versus situations where it's really genuinely unhealthy and someone's genuinely out to get you kind of thing, you know.
Yeah, well, that was something I was really interested in asking you about is like, I think we use the term like toxic to describe a whole different pattern of behaviours. What are some of the key ones that you think are most typical in those, like, Yeah, in like complex family dynamics. Like what are some of the behaviors that we should be looking out for to identify that like maybe this relationship, although its family, is actually not that healthy. Yeah. So I guess like you've got to like pull apart like what is because I always say like when
you're trying to form new relationships like the biggest thing that you can do is just like number one seek to understand. You don't have to agree but try and see where someone's coming from because sometimes you can look at it from a place off, oh wow. A big one that I get is women who don't get along with their sister-in-laws. And I think a lot of that stems from, you've taken my brother away from me. I'm getting defensive. So if you can understand it from that perspective, you're like,
can I crack this person and get them to like me? Because they're just feeling a little bit insecure right now. They're feeling like this person's being taken away from them. If I can approach it in a clever way, I can turn this around. Not that it's on your shoulders, but you could potentially by, you know, opening up to them and being vulnerable to that person. And then they're like, oh, you're a human just like me. You're not this big, scary girlfriend that swept in and taken my brother, who's my best
friend. You're actually a feeling human and then they can open up versus you genuinely feeling attacked because the family might not agree with, you know, the fact that it's a big one is it's a gay relationship or it's a divide in beliefs or they don't like your lifestyle. So they're just like, we don't accept you. That's it. And to try and all parents, a huge one is where mothers don't want to let go of their sons, sometimes daughters as well.
But I find a really common one is moms like digging their heels in being like, it's my baby, and they want to like coddle their adult son. And it's like, how do you? Yeah. And I've got heaps of listeners, but friends as well who really struggle with that one and trying to have a decent relationship with the mother-in-law is a huge one. And then when it comes to like Christmas, holiday season, they want their kids, adult kids with them all the time. They want nothing to have changed.
So it's, I guess it's really difficult to navigate this relationship when they're the ones that have to, like they've got their kids. They've got to accept that their kids are growing up and the dynamic is going to change. And a lot of families can't accept that. They can't accept change. Whereas you're the one who's like, well, I'm just growing into this world. I'm becoming an adult. I'm experiencing all these new things. Why am I being attacked? What have I done wrong? I'm listening to that being like applying that to so many situations in my own life. And I'm like, wow, that is actually quite universal. That is so universal.
You made such a good point there. I think the reason why a lot of us in our 20s in particular start to experience this friction for the first time is because we are, it is the first kind of period or chapter in our life in which we are rejecting the label of child. And that's just not like personally. That's like saying almost to our families, I'm not a kid anymore. Like your relationship to me might be that I'm your child, but I'm also an adult who is trying to set up their own life
who has boundaries around how I want to be treated now. And I think it's also natural to go through a period where you detach from your family and then you come back. The other one that I think is really interesting, which comes up all the time during this period is differing political beliefs. And I find this in my own family quite a bit. My parents are, not with my parents per se, but with like my extended family where just because you're related doesn't mean you're going to agree on everything.
What's some of your advice from that? Have you seen that like in your friendship group as well? Definitely. Definitely. And when it comes to political, this is it like a really good topic because I feel like when it comes to difference in politics, one thing that I always raise with my family, my in-laws, with anyone who might differ in their political police friends, is that I say, there's a difference between a debate, I love a debate, versus an argument. And I don't think it's the healthiest thing to become emotionally attached to a political party. You should be able to criticize the party that
you are voting for. That's what makes an informed decision. So when I see people get really emotional and angry about a political thing. It's like, are you forming your identity around this attachment or are you able to be like, this is the right party for this time to run this country? You know, so you should be able to flick between political parties. You shouldn't make your identity about a party. And if you happen to align with a party for your whole life, fine. That's great. But it's this idea if I think people feel when you attack the political party, you're attacking me. Now I'm going to get angry. Now I'm going to get defensive. But it's Like I'm not, I'm just raising something.
Have you thought about it in this way? Have you looked at it in that way? And I always say to people, I like to debate, but if you're going to start character assassinating me, then I can't have this conversation. But I'd love to discuss. I'd love, I don't have to change your mind. You don't have to change mind.
But I like, I like seeing how other people think. Yeah. And teaching me why they think that way, as long as they're open to hearing the same back. It's like coming at it from approach of, of like openness and learning. I always, I was saying this to someone the other day, you sometimes get into these discussions with people
and you can see it in their eyes that they are looking for an argument. Like, do you know what I'm talking about? It's like this fire where it's like you can see that something has lit up in them where you can tell in those moments that what you're talking about for you might be a discussion for them as a projection of their identity. Big time. And those are the topics that you need to just, I think, step away from.
Step away from. Yeah, definitely. And the people that, and you can figure this out really, really quickly, when you speak to someone and you can tell that they're just thinking of the next thing they're going to say instead of listening to what you're actually saying and responding accordingly. So it's like, I know you're just brewing up your next argument. You're not listening to me. So I think sometimes you also have to just pick your battles with certain people.
You're not going to be able to have a healthy debate with everybody. And sometimes I think while you are in your right to say what you want to say, Sometimes I think for your own peace of mind, just don't. Just for your own sake. You just suffer. Sometimes you cause yourself all this suffering because you're like, but I can have these conversations with these people, but they're different people. You've got to manage your expectations around people.
Especially with family. It's like I think it's hard because I think when we're talking about dealing with difficult family members, right? Like we have a few categories here. Yeah. We have, as you said, like the relationship. relationships where there is friction caused by change, where, you know, the son has grown up and gotten a girlfriend and the mother is like really struggling to deal with that. I think that's like environmental. I think part of that is also we can put in like political beliefs as well. There's like a there is again a friction in that sense of like there is a disagreement. Then you have like genuine clinically severe behaviors. Yes. Like narcissism like compulsive liars like even abuse or controlling behavior. Then you have like genuine clinically. which we'll talk about more in a second. And then I think you have this other side,
which is parents who are really, or family members who are really trying their best, but are dealing with something that is making it so your relationship is afraid. So I got this question the other day from someone that was talking about how her mother is experiencing a really bad episode of depression. And that is by nature creating difficult,
difficulties in their relationship, creating a difficult dynamic where her mother is probably not, isn't really acting in a way that I think is how we would see a mother acting because of what's going on. How do you think we deal with those different categories of people? Like the friction, the like the clinical severe and then just the people who are perhaps not in a great place. Yeah. So with people that are not in a great place, I always say whether it could be depression or like there's so many different, you know, categories. But always try and remind yourself that that person is not the depression. That person is not the X, Y, Z, you know, they are two separate things.
So sometimes someone might treat you in a certain way or push you away or create conflict within the relationship because they're going through this internal suffering. And it impacts the relationship. And it's, you know, ideally you want to find a way. So the relationship doesn't break down. You want to find a way of being like, every time I have this interaction, have to be at the forefront of my mind has to be they are not the depression and them are two separate things and the depression will get in the way and that's not their intention so how do you
find a way to maintain your boundaries for your own mental health but also have patience and understanding in that space and sometimes you might need to pull away just a little bit and be there for them but say you know like I can't spend 10 hours with my mom now because it's I leave and I'm in a state. But maybe I can find different ways of really being there for her. That's just going to have to be different. Sometimes your relationships will have to evolve in a different way. So you feel like you're still there for them.
But you also have to, you know, protect yourself as well. So you're not also going to be spiraling as well. I think that all relationships are always evolving. And to think, and this is where a lot of problems with relationships start with parents, the dynamic between parents and children, is that you always have to look at relationships as evolving. If you accuse someone of you've changed, it's like, well, that's inevitable. Of course they've changed. Everyone's going to change. And when I look at my relationship with my partner, I know that we're going to go through many relationships within this one relationship. Who will
be when we're 40 is not who we were when we met. And it's your job to try your best to evolve together, you know, but to think, I never changed, you changed. And this is why the marriage broke down, which happens all the time or with parents and kids. It's like, well, isn't that what we're supposed to do? Aren't we supposed to evolve and change? And that can happen for the worse as well. You know, with someone getting sick, someone having, you know, some disorder. You've got to find a way to come into that next phase of the relationship and it will be different.
Yeah, it's really hard when that happens, I think, because we all like to talk about unconditional love and unconditional love sounds brilliant and I do think it's possible. but I think especially as you begin to realize that your parents are human too we see them as being on this like pedestal for a lot of our lives for so long yeah for so long and I think that all of us have a moment and I'm sure you have one yeah where you were like oh my parent is like my my mom my dad is this is their first time being alive as well like they are figuring all of this out at the same time as me they're just a little bit further along. So true. And it's so, I think that's difficult when you see them go through
hard periods. And maybe it's like hard periods in your parents' marriage. Maybe it's like how your relationship with your parent is going to adapt post-divorce. Like, exactly. And seeing them suffer and seeing them overcome things and being like, wow, you were this this untouchable thing when I was a kid who knew everything. And now I'm realizing that, you know, I'm soon going to be the age that you were at, you know, and you just start having, it's like, wow, how are you parenting and I'm that age now? And, you know, it's just, it blows your mind to realize you didn't have it all figured out when I was a kid. And maybe giving them that, um, if it is like the right decision for you, giving them that level of like, um, not just forgiveness, but like that, that space to make mistakes
hard periods. And maybe it's like hard periods in your parents' marriage. Maybe it's like how your relationship with your parent is going to adapt post-divorce. Like, exactly. And seeing them suffer and seeing them overcome things and being like, wow, you were this this untouchable thing when I was a kid who knew everything. And now I'm realizing that, you know, I'm soon going to be the age that you were at, you, and you just start having, it's like, wow, how are you parenting and I'm that age now? And, you know, it's just, it blows your mind to realize you didn't have it all figured out when I was a kid. And maybe giving them that, um, if it is like the right decision for you, giving them that level of like, um, not just forgiveness, but like that, that space to make mistakes
as much as you are still. Like, I think viewing, it's not that you need to view your parents as a friend because I think that changes the dynamic. It does. It does. And it's, it's, can be quite difficult, but viewing them as just as fallible, just as, like, flawed as you are and the same way that you would want other people to accept your mistakes, you should be willing to accept a degree of their mistakes as well. I think that's really important. There are some instances, though, where that is not possible. Exactly. Yeah. And you mentioned narcissists. Yeah. And narcissistic parents or in-laws is like a really difficult one to navigate. You have a great episode on this, by the way. I do have a specific episode on that.
So good. Because I did one on narcissists. And then I had all these people being like, what about mother-in-law? What about my mom? What about my dad? And so I thought, okay, well, this absolutely. I'll put it in the description. Because you hear a lot about narcissists in relationships.
And normally you'll hear it being the man who's the narcissist and the woman who's dating it. But then when you hear about, because you can have just as many female as male, it's hard to put a number on it because a lot of people who are narcissists aren't going and getting diagnosed. As narcissists, so it's more. Probably extreme, not probably, it's definitely extremely underdiagnosed. But that's when you see it's like, oh, this is across all genders, you know, it doesn't matter. Narcissistic parents are a huge one. And the weird thing is that often the child, so say you're dating someone and their parents are clearly narcissists, often the person you're dating doesn't realize that.
They're just like, oh, they're just difficult. Oh, they make all these excuses similar to what we were just talking about before, where your parents are these, you want them to be perfect. They're your parents. You are them. You know, you're, that's why, like, it hurts to see your parent criticize the other parent because you're like, you're criticizing half of me. You know, it's really, that's why children suffer in divorce if it's a horrible divorce
because they feel torn, you know. And so when you, when you're trying to let your partner realize, without being aggressive, how do you get your partner to really identify that their parents are narcissistic? Sometimes they see it. Sometimes they don't. And when they don't see it, it's really hard to navigate. that. So I always say, don't straight up say to someone, your parents are narcissist, your mother is a narcissist. I always start with, always put the question back on them. Like, does this
behavior happen all the time? When, you know, start getting them to do some self-discovery? When was the first time they did something like that? Or when was the first time they put you in that position? And do they do that with all your siblings? And you just start like, just, just questions. And then they were like, oh, wow, oh, yeah, right, that's not weird. And then they figure it out for themselves. You just got to get, dig under the surface. And then it's, then you create an environment where it's comfortable for them to talk about it and never ever character assassinate your partner's parents, no matter how annoyed you are, because again, you're insulting them, you know, like obviously you're not meaning to, but that's how they perceive
it as. It's like the whole thing of like, oh, I'm allowed to talk shit about this person, but the moment you do, it's not okay. You know, like you'll break up with someone and then you're allowed to say everything under the sun about that person, but then if someone insults, you're like, oh, what, what, you're like, I loved them. So what does that say about me? Yeah, yeah. What do you do? What are you, are you judging my judgment or my choices? And you know that they're right. Same thing with siblings. You know, they're right. Yes. It's like, I'm allowed to say whatever I want about my sisters. The minute, like, they come to me again, one of their friends has said something like, oh my God. I'm like, I'm going to fucking hunt you dare. Like, how dare you say that.
How rude. But then you can say it, you know, so it's kind of that dynamic. So I think definitely tread carefully, but I think that if you can set up a really comfortable open space to have a conversation about the behaviours of your parents. Always say, like, turn it into speaking about the behaviour and not them as a person. This behaviour is unhealthy. This behaviour is unacceptable. I'm going to put a boundary against this interaction or this situation, so it doesn't happen again.
And then you're not saying, they're an asshole, they're an idiot, they're fucked in the head. You know, because if you start saying stuff like that, then that's when... It comes across as you, like, genuinely, even if you do. It makes it look like you hate their parents. And it's how do I navigate this carefully? Because if your partner didn't have a good enough relationship with their parents, that wouldn't be an issue. Because the only reason you say your in-laws is because your partner has a good relationship with their in-laws.
So the difficulty in navigating it is when your partner has that relationship. And you've got a slot in there somehow. It's also really interesting because it kind of shows this weird distinguishing. right? Not so much a distinction, but as somewhat of an innate competition as we get older between the family we grew up with and the family that we're going on to create. And I think that sometimes it's very easy for people to be like, well, this is my family now. I need to prioritize my partner and our future together. But that's also a really hard distinction for some people to make there is still that innate loyalty to the people that have raised them. And maybe you are
someone who is recognizing for yourself that your own parents are like that. How do you go about, I guess, it might not even be narcissism. It might be that in the past, things were not as healthy as they are now. They might still be unhealthy, toxic, whatever label you want to give it. How do you go about having those difficult conversations once you have identified and done some of that exploration and realized that this person or, though you may love them is perhaps not a good figure in your life right now. Yeah, that's really hard, as we all know.
Like, I think it's really hard to bring up to somebody that they, to criticize their parenting. Yeah. Because for a parent, their biggest job, their biggest accomplishment is raising a human, more than one human, you know, and to go in and criticize them, it's so hard to do, to do it, like delicately. And even if you do it in the most delicate way, they're not going to take it in the best way possible. But I do still think, obviously, it's important to do so.
And when setting a boundary, when saying something, the best way to start is you say, I no longer feel comfortable with this. Or you make it about you. Every time I set a boundary, I make sure that it's about me. Because if I say, you do this and you do that and you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, then it feels like it's an attack. And it feels like I'm trying to control how they're behaving.
But if I say, listen, next time this situation arises, I don't want to be here if you're going to start yelling at me. Or I don't want to, you know, you try and just make it a bit more about I'm going to draw a line here. I've got a friend of mine and she had a really unhealthy relationship with her partner's mom. And I just said to her, you're going over every Sunday and you're spending like 10 hours or eight hours at the... Ten hours. And just so unpleasant the environment.
Yeah, I can imagine. And then I said, firstly, why don't you draw a line and say, I don't have to go every Sunday, for starters. I don't. I'm my own person. I'm an adult. And when I do go, I can either come a little bit later or I can leave a bit earlier. And then that just shows a level of independence,
and it's like an unsaid rule of like, I can control myself here. Like, I want to come and see you, but I'm not. handering to everything that you want, you know, just because my partner wants to be here for 10 hours, I don't have to. And it's not about being rude, you've come in, you give them the time of day, you have the conversation you're putting in the effort, but then you're saying, okay, so good to see you guys, say you're, bye, and just like remove yourself from there.
Yeah, no question about it. Like, no, I will not stay for coffee. Because sometimes the hard thing is that sometimes you'll have the best idea for the best conversation and you'll say, and it's just not going to be taken in the right way and they're just going to feel attacked. sometimes a conversation cannot be had. And the only thing you can do is, okay, given what I've got, like given what's in front of me, I have to work with what I've got.
是的，毫无疑问。比如，不，我不留下来喝咖啡了。因为有时候困难的地方在于，有时你会有最好的对话的最佳想法，然后你把话说出来，但却不会被正确对待，他们只会觉得自己受到了攻击。有时有些对话是无法进行的。你唯一能做的就是，好吧，根据我目前拥有的，也就是根据我眼前的情况，我必须利用我手头的东西来处理。
And the best way to work with what I've got is to limit the interaction. So when I'm there, I'll just give it my all, but it's small doses. And then you find I can actually handle these people in small doses. Like a lot of people, they're like, oh, I love my in-laws, because they live three hours flying off flight away, you know. So we go there. I just don't get my time. I do my best.
而处理我手头状况的最佳方式就是限制互动。所以当我在那里的时候，我会全力以赴，但只限于少量的接触。然后你会发现，其实我可以应付这些人，只要接触时间不长。就像很多人一样，他们会说，哦，我爱我的公婆/岳父母，因为他们住在三个小时飞机航程之外的地方，你知道的。所以我们去那儿。我只是不会待太久。我尽力而为。
We don't, like, we clash, but it's fine. And then I leave. If they were my neighbors, I'd hate them. So it's that kind of, so how can you navigate that if you live in the same city? Just like bring it back a little bit. Feel like you're a little bit more in control of yourself. And I think that will really help you feel like, you know, not so much anxiety when you then have to go spend time with potential in-laws or even your own parents who might be causing you so much, so much stress. But then you've got like the really unhealthy relationship.
我们不会，呃，我们会有冲突，但没关系。然后我就离开。如果他们是我的邻居，我会恨死他们。所以就是那种情况，如果你住在同一个城市，你该如何应对呢？只要稍微收敛一点。让自己感觉对自己的掌控更多一点。我认为这真的会帮助你感觉到，你知道的，当你不得不花时间去陪伴潜在的公婆/岳父母，甚至是那些可能会给你带来巨大、巨大压力的亲生父母时，你的焦虑感就不会那么强烈了。但随后你会遇到真正不健康的关系。
And I always say, like, just because you are tied together by blood, no one has a ticket into your life for free. No one's got this golden ticket into your life. People have to earn their place in your life just like you have to earn your place in someone else's life. You can't go around disrespecting someone indefinitely and expect for your seat to still be there. So if it means cutting out someone because they treat you like shit, cut the person out, you know. And I think that there's some steps. I totally agree with that as well. I think there are some steps to take beforehand.
而我总是说，仅仅因为你们有血缘关系，就没有任何人拥有免费进入你生活的门票。没有人拥有通往你生活的那张金券。人们必须赢得他们在你生活中的位置，就像你必须赢得你在别人生活中的位置一样。你不能到处无休止地不尊重别人，还指望你的座位依然为你保留。所以，如果这意味着因为某人像对待垃圾一样对待你而将他们从你的生活中剔除，那就把这个人剔除吧，你知道的。而且我认为有一些步骤。我完全同意这一点。我认为在此之前需要采取一些步骤。
The example that you just gave was like reestablishing your independence as an individual that goes for your in-laws and then also for your own parents, even for like sibling relationships that are quite draining or codependent or any form of family relationship, maintaining a sense of independence when that person is trying to take more from you than you're willing to give is a huge one. But I do think there is something to be said about setting boundaries and seeing how people respond. Sometimes the outcome of a boundary is not that their behaviour changes, but that you see that they're incapable of doing it.
你刚才举的例子就像是重新确立你作为个体的独立性，这不仅适用于你的公婆/岳父母，也适用于你自己的父母，甚至对于那些相当消耗能量或共生的兄弟姐妹关系，或者任何形式的家庭关系，当那个人试图从你这里索取多于你愿意付出的东西时，保持一种独立感是非常重要的一点。但我确实认为，关于设定界限并观察人们的反应，有些话值得一说。有时设定界限的结果并不是他们的行为改变了，而是你发现他们根本做不到这一点。
That is something that I've started to realize where it's like, I think we often talk about, oh, you need to set a boundary, and we are like, oh, and then immediately assume that that person is going to meet that boundary once it's been spoken into existence. That's right. And they don't. A lot of the time. And that is actually just as, it might be disappointing, but it's just as valid.
这是我开始意识到的事情，就像是，我想我们经常谈论，哦，你需要设定一个界限，然后我们就会觉得，哦，并立即假设一旦这个界限被说出口，那个人就会满足这个界限。没错。但他们并没有。很多时候都是这样。而这实际上同样，这可能会让人失望，但它对你了解他们的行为同样具有价值。确实如此。有时设定界限并不意味着它会受到尊重，但你已经明确表达了你的极限在哪里。现在这不再是一件随心所欲的事了。这就像是，我已经告诉你那个极限在哪里了。无论你是否尊重它，如何回应你对它的尊重，这取决于我。但我总是说，除非有后果，否则界限就不是界限。你知道的，你不能说，这是我的界限，却任由它每次都被践踏。
valuable to you to teach you about their behavior. It is. And sometimes setting a boundary doesn't mean that it's going to be respected, but you've vocalized where your limit is. And now it's not this arbitrary thing. It's like, I've now told you where that limit is. Whether you respect it or not, it's up to me how to respond to you respecting. But I always say a boundary is not a boundary unless there are consequences. You know, you can't say, this is my boundary and have it stomped all over every time.
这不是界限。这是你的，你希望它是你的界限。但除非跨越这个界限会有后果，否则它就不是界限。哦，这真是个好观点。我想到这一点，比如，跟我的一位家庭成员有关，他真的有对别人的外表评头论足的问题，我认为这是一个大问题。哦，天哪。我懂。
It's not a boundary. It's your, you wish it was your boundary. but unless there is a consequence for that boundary being crossed, it's not a boundary. Oh, that's such a good point. I think about this, like, in relation to a family member of mine who has a real problem with making comments about people's appearances, which I think is a big one. Oh, my God. I get it.
就像，不同的一代人。我完全理解他们认为这没问题。但我不再理解了，因为我认为。我们已经向他们非常明确地表达过了。我的兄弟姐妹也卷入了这件事。我的意思是，不，你不能再做那些评论了。当你说没有后果的界限就不是界限时，我们曾多年来一直说，请不要这么说，请不要这么说。
Like, different generation. I totally understand that they think that's fine. But I don't understand it anymore because I think. think that we have been very clear with them. My siblings have also been like involved in this. I mean like, no, you cannot make those comments anymore. And when you said a boundary is not a boundary without consequences, we were for years being like, please don't say that, please don't say that.
我听到你这么说很不舒服。直到我们说出类似这样的话：如果你再这么说，我们就再也不会来这里了。完全正确。他们才反应过来，哦，或者像是，好吧，我真的很不喜欢那样。我现在就要走了。完全正确。如果你站起来离开，那是一个巨大的。表态，意思是这让我很不舒服，你把事情搞得这么令人不快，是的，我宁愿不
I'm uncomfortable with you saying that. It was only when we were like, if you say that, we won't be coming here anymore. Exactly. That they were like, oh, or like, okay, I really didn't enjoy that. I'm leaving now. Exactly. If you stand up and leave, that's a huge. statement of like it's that uncomfortable for me you've made this so unpleasant yeah I'd rather not
待在这里，真的。这就是那种，哦，哇，这就是当他们真的，不幸的是事情必须发展到那个地步，但这才是他们意识到，哦，天哪，他们竟然愿意离开，是的，这真的太不应该了，你知道的，这真的，而且我认为，这确实很不舒服，身处那些时刻很不舒服，但离开他们也很不舒服，当然，因为我认为这就是另一回事，人们无法总是设定有效的界限的原因在于，我们认为设定界限只是一件像你刚才说的那样，仅仅是表达我们希望如何被对待的意图，而不是真正去付诸行动。那么，有哪些技巧可以用来：
be here literally and that's when it's like oh wow this is that's when they really unfortunately it has to get to that point but that's when they realize oh my god the fact that they're willing to leave yeah that's really not okay you know it really and I think it was and it was uncomfortable it was uncomfortable being in those moments but it was also uncomfortable walking away from them of course because I think that that's the other thing people the reason that we cannot always set boundaries that work is because we think that setting your boundary is just a matter of just like you said, of just saying, setting an intention for how we want to be treated rather than actually instigating it. So what are some tips for being like,
首先识别界限？其次，真正坚持下去，坚持并执行它。是的。所以有两个方面，因为你可以从这个角度来看，我的意思是，你可以称之为界限，但在你的脑海里你可以说，听着，我可以要求别人以某种特定方式跟我说话，你知道的，但最终我决定了，无论他们如何对待我，我绝不离开，但我只是可以提出要求。这是一回事。这就是你对对方的反应零期待，你只会觉得，好吧，无论发生什么，我都全盘接受。第二种是这样的界限：你觉得，好吧，只有当你清楚知道一旦界限被跨越时会是什么样子时，才去设定界限。所以当你宣称，我正在设定这个界限时，
firstly identifying a boundary? Secondly, really sticking to it, sticking to it and enforcing it as well. Yeah. So there's two, because you can look at it in, I mean, you can call it a boundary, but in your head you can say, look, I could request that someone speak to me. certain way, you know, but ultimately I've just decided that no matter how they treat me, I'm never walking away, but I could just request it. That's one thing. And that's where you have zero expectations of the response and you'd just be like, all right, whatever comes, I'm just going to accept. The second one is the boundary where you're like, okay, only set a boundary when you know what it looks like once it's crossed. So when you say, I'm setting this boundary,
如果他们越界了，接下来会发生什么？我打算怎么做？因为我现在设定了一个预期。界限带有预期。而请求，最好没有。就像，你希望他们开始对你好一点，但同时你也会说，你能求求你吗？他们的回答可能是“不”，然后你会觉得，好吧，真行。然而对于界限，你会想，好吧，如果我要设定这个界限，我必须愿意知道如果他们越界了会是什么样子，并确切知道我的行动会是什么。为自己制定一个行动计划。不要因为如果你去说，这是我的界限。然后他们越界了，接着你就会想，哦，然后你语塞了，接着压力全落在了你自己的身上，你感觉糟透了，然后你觉得自己的根基被动摇了。
what now happens if they cross that boundary? What am I going to do? Because I've now put an expectation. A boundary has an expectation. A request, hopefully doesn't. Like, you would like them to start treating you nicely, but also you're like, could you please? And their answer could be no, and you're like, okay, sick. Whereas the boundary, you're like, all right, if I'm going to set this boundary, I have to be willing to know what it looks like if they cross it and know exactly what my actions will be. Make a game plan for yourself. Don't because then if you go and say, this is my boundary. And then they cross it, then you're like, oh, and you choke up and then the pressure's on yourself and you feel terrible and then you feel like you've been undermined.
是的。又一次，你会觉得，这只会进一步伤害这段关系。然后你的自信心受挫，你会觉得，好吧，现在我的话没有任何分量了，因为如果我试图设定另一个界限，他们没有尊重那一个，他们也不会尊重这个。
Yes. Once again, you're like, it just hurts the relationship further. And then your confidence is shot and you're like, well, now my word means nothing because now if I try and set another boundary, they didn't respect that one. They're not going to respect this one.
所以在你设定界限之前，先对自己进行一番心理建设，告诉自己，好吧，如果我要设定这个界限，当他们跨越它时会发生什么？我的行动会是什么？我认为最好的办法就是把自己从那种处境中抽离出来。而且不要把它搞得像是一个普遍适用的，比如：
So before you go in with the boundary, give yourself a bit of a bit of a bit of talk and be like, okay, if I'm going to set this boundary, what happens when they cross set? What will my actions be? I think the best one is to remove yourself from the situation. And don't make it this universal, like,
我再也不会回来了。不，只需说，就像你做的那样。这其实很简单，当这种情况发生时，我不会留在这个空间里。所以如果你在我到达的第一分钟就这么说，我就离开。如果你在一小时后说，我就离开。如果你要那样跟我说话，我就不在这里了。
I'm never coming back. No, just say, I'm like you did. It's something simple as when this happens, I'm not going to be in this space. So if you say it in the first minute of me arriving, I leave. If you say it after an hour, I leave. I'm just not going to be here if you're going to talk to me like that.
你也可以说，你会发现，你做得越多，我优先考虑和你一起出去玩，而不是去参加可能收到的其他邀请的意愿就会越少。而且，你知道的，不管你喜不喜欢，人们对于自己想和谁共度时光确实有一个等级制度。那就是那些能让他们在对方面前最做自己的人。无论从血缘关系来看他们跟你有多亲近，这些人都是你放在名单最顶部的人。所以我想如果你能，如果你觉得足够自在，能够说：
And you can also say, and you'll realize that the more you do it, the less I'm going to want to prioritize hanging out with you versus hanging out with another invitation that it might have had. And, you know, people, whether you like it or not, people do have a hierarchy of who they want to spend time with. And it's the ones that they feel the most comfortable than themselves. around. They're the people you put at the top of that list, no matter how close they are or not to you as far as blood goes. So I think if you can, if you feel comfortable enough to be like,
好吧，如果发生这种情况，我就走开，那就设定这个界限。你甚至都不用说出来。比如，你甚至不需要表现得。你不需要明说。所以我想到了一个故事。我的另一个朋友说，一个很大的雷同点是关于评论，不仅是外表，还有关于你做出的任何形式的选择的评论。你的生活方式，你是如何？甚至包括你的性取向之类的事情，那些你别无选择的事情，那种感觉就像是，你在这里到底想干什么？就像你想改变我的想法一样？这太荒谬了。我觉得这是一个大问题。
okay, if this happens, I'm walking away, then set that boundary. And you don't even have to say it. Like, you don't even have to be like. You don't have to know. So I think about this in terms of a story. Another friend of mine said, a big one is comments about not just appearance, but comments about any kind of choice that you're making. Your lifestyle, how you? Or even things that like your sexuality, things that you don't have a choice around where it's like, what are you trying to do here? Like you're trying to change my mind. Like that's ridiculous. Like I think that's a big one.
另一个是那些强迫性说谎者或控制欲强的人。比如那些会说，你现在能做这个吗？或者像那些，是的，我认为这是一个很大的问题，他们会说，哦，如果你在我的房子里，你就得做这做那。是的，控制欲。是的，我发现控制欲强和强迫性说谎者。我认为这两类人都可以归入这样一个范畴，我认为当人们
The other one is people who are compulsive liars or controlling. So people who are like, can you do this now? Or like who are, yeah, I think that's a huge one where they're like, oh, if you're in my house, you have to do X, Y and Z. Yes. Controlling. Yeah. And I find that controlling and compulsing. liars. I think both of those things will fall under the category of, I think when people
无法控制自己时，他们就会控制周围的所有人。因此，你对自我和现状的掌控力越少，你就会越试图控制所有人。看看那些关系，它们是如此具有控制欲，这些人对他们为自己创造的生活并不满意。所以他们会想，既然我觉得自己的生活失控了，我要控制你，从而让我觉得自已拥有力量。情况也是如此。你知道，比如让别人帮他们做事。你知道，这必须完成。你来到了我的地盘，现在你得做这个。这一切都源于他们对自己生活的失控感，以及缺乏满足感，我感觉得到。这太悲哀了。就像是移情，对吧？就像是
can't control themselves, they control everyone else around them. So the less control you have over who you are and your circumstances, you try and control everyone. You look at those relationships where they're so controlling, these people are not happy with the life they've created for themselves. So they're like, given that I feel like I'm out of control in my circumstances, I'm going to control you and feel like I'm empowered. And the same goes for that. You know, like getting people to do things for them. You know, this has to be done. You've come into my space and now you've got to do this. It's all about a lack of control in their own life and a lack of satisfaction as well, I feel. That's so sad. It's like displacement, right? Like yeah.
典型的弗洛伊德理论。确实如此。你会觉得有点内疚。你会想，哦，我真替你感到遗憾。是的。就是这样，对吧？如果他们以那种方式行事，你大可以走开，甚至不需要说“我现在要走了”这样的话。比如，晚点发短信给他们，就说，好吧，我的缺席就是一种信息。希望他们能领会。如果你没有自信。没有信心真正说出口的话。而且我认为，是的，是的，你刚才说自信的那一点非常重要，因为我认为很多人会觉得，除了我必须采取这个行动之外，我接下来还得说点什么。
Classic Freudian. It is. You kind of feel a bit bad. You're like, oh, I feel sorry for you. Yeah. And that's the thing, right? If they're acting in that way, you can just walk away without even being like, I'm leaving now. Like, and text them later, just be like, okay, my absence is a is a message here. And hopefully they pick up on it. If you don't have the confidence. confidence to actually say that. And I think, yeah, yeah, that's a huge one, what you just said with the confidence, because I think a lot of people think, on top of the fact that I've got to do this action, I then have to say something.
而且很多人，他们过往的人生中并没有那种在任何时候有想法时都能自信说出话的经历。这非常困难，对一个自信的人来说，这就像是，我直接说就行了。但事实并非如此。对很多人来说，你什么意思，你想让我这辈子第一次顶撞我的父母？你知道的，这让人望而生畏。所以就像你说的，你不需要说些什么。你只需离开。
And a lot of people, they've not lived a life where they've just confidently said things whenever they thought it. And it's very difficult, for a confident person, it's like, I'll just say it. But it's not like that. For a lot of people, what do you mean you want me to stand up to my parents for the first time ever? You know, it's daunting. So like you said, you don't have to say something. You can just leave.
我总是说，一条短信，一封信，一封亲手写的寄出的信。无论用什么方式，只要能让你在头脑冷静、心平气和的情况下把观点表达清楚，就是最好的方法。如果你能当面说，那很好，但大多数人做不到，因为这太焦虑了，太有压力了。你回到家后有一大堆好话要说。我当时怎么没把这些话说出来呢？你知道的，只要抽身离开，冷静下来，写下你需要说的所有内容
And I always say a text message, a letter, handwritten letter in the mail. but whatever to get your point across where you're cool, calm and collected is the best way to do it. If you can do it in person, great, but most people can't because they're like, it's anxiety, it's so stressful. You've got all these good things to say the moment you get home. Why didn't I say all these things? You know, just remove yourself, cool, like calm down, write everything you need to say
然后过一会儿再读一遍，不要，不要马上发出去。是的，然后想着：我稍微修改一下再发，你知道的，这或许是一种可行的方法。你刚才说的另一件事，当时我就觉得，那是采取这种做法的另一个真正很好的理由，因为在当时的那一刻，正如你所说，你可能正在经历极大的焦虑。铺天盖地。这是你第一次对家庭成员说，嘿，这不可接受。有时人们对此反应会非常强烈。而这将会升级到这样的地步，即你对他们的反应做出了强烈的回击。
and then read it later, not, don't send it straight away. Yeah. And then be like, I'll edit that a little bit and then send it, you know, that might be away. The other thing that you said there where I was like, that is another really good reason to do that is because in the moment, like you said, you are probably going to be experiencing a great deal of anxiety. Massively. One of the first times you've ever been like to a family member, hey, not acceptable. Sometimes people can be really reactive to that. And that is going to escalate to the point where you are really reactive to how they've responded.
人们的情绪会变得非常激动。你会觉得你对局势的掌控感，你为自己发声的能力正在一点点流失。因为在这个时候，这个人有点像是在进行情感战。完全是。你知道的，无论是有意还是无意。是的。而且愤怒是最初潜在情绪的次生情绪。
And people get really worked up. you're going to feel like your sense of control over the situation, your ability to speak up for yourself is slipping. Because this person is kind of using emotional warfare at that point. Totally. You know, intentionally unintentionally. Yeah. And like anger is a secondary emotion to an initial underlying emotion.
所以当有人生气时，如果你也很生气，那么就你们能达到的地步而言，这局游戏就结束了。因为如果两个都在生气，他们实际上是在用愤怒来试图传达这样一种事实：他们感到被抛弃、被拒绝、感到不安全、感到受到了攻击，你知道的，但表现出来的是愤怒。所以它是具有攻击性的。因此，如果你竖起高墙并用攻击性来回应，你将一无所获。这就是为什么你们会陷入这种僵局，并且好几天不说话。这简直，所以当有人生气时，我总是说，跟一个生气的人是没话可说的。如果你还没陷入愤怒之中，那就离开，抽身走人。
So when someone gets angry, if you're also angry, it's game over as far as where you can go from there. Because if two people are angry, they're actually using anger to try and communicate the fact that they feel abandoned, that they feel rejected, that they feel insecure, that they feel attacked, you know, but it's anger. So it's aggressive. And so you put your wall up and respond with aggression, you get nowhere. And that's where you go through this like standoff and you don't talk for days. It's just, so when someone gets angry, I always say like, there's no talking to someone who's angry. And if you have yet to slip into anger, leave, just remove yourself.
逃跑吧。是的。而且不要说“冷静点”，因为那只会火上浇油。只需说，我宁愿以后再谈这个。是的。为了摆脱这种局面，即使你没有情绪爆发，我曾被建议说这样的话：等我们都冷静下来后再谈这个，你知道的，这样你就把它定性为：我们现在都在气头上。让我们只是。而不是单指你。
Run away. Yeah. And don't be like, calm down, because that will just stir someone even more. just say, I'd rather talk about this. Yeah. And to take ownership off it, even if you're not blowing up, I was advised to say something like, let's talk about this when we've both calmed down, you know, so you make it like, we are heated. Let's just. Not just you.
是的，是的，是的，是的，因为我脑子里现在也在发热。所以我觉得，永远不要对愤怒做出回应。根本不值得。正如你所知，你知道的，当人们情绪激动时。很难保持理智，很难提出合乎逻辑的论点或陈述。你被情绪主导了。一切都是本能反应。你没有进行前瞻性思考。你没有在进行推理。这就是为什么走开冷静一会儿，思考一下“我实际上在感受什么”，对他们是有好处的，你知道的？特别是如果你也是一个敏感的人。是的。那是如果别人的情绪，
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, because I'm heated in my head right now. And so I think, yeah, never respond to anger. It's just not worth it. And as you would know, you know, when people are, fired up. It's harder to be logic, to make a logical argument or a statement. You're emotional. It's all reactive. You're not thinking proactively. You're not reasoning. So that's why it would benefit them to walk off and cool off for a bit and think about, okay, what am I actually feeling, you know? Especially if you're a sensitive person as well. Yeah. That's if someone else's emotions,
如果你是一个共情能力强的人，就像，你会察觉到那些情绪。一旦有人达到了无法控制自己情绪的地步，这是无法控制的。你将会察觉到这一点。你会吸收这些情绪。非常严重。非常严重。然后这真的很痛。痛彻心扉。你只是在保护自己。而结果却是一场灾难。所以我说，是的，一定要退一步。就像你说的，你当时不需要说任何话。如果你以前没有过，你不需要表现得像个非常自信的人。你不需要这么做。你完全可以抽身离开，沉淀下来，然后以感觉最好的方式进行沟通，你知道的。绝佳的建议。谢谢。
if you're an empath, like, you're going to pick up on those. There's no controlling that once someone has gotten to the point where they can't manage. They're, emotions. You are going to pick up on that. You're going to absorb that. Big time. Big time. And then it's, it hurts. It hurts so much. You're trying to protect yourself. And it's just a disaster. So I say, yeah, definitely step away. Like you said, you don't have to say anything in the moment. You don't have to try and be this really confident person if you haven't before. You don't have to. You can just remove, simmer down and then communicate in the way that feels best, you know. Great advice. Thank you.
我真正想关注的最后一件事，因为我收到了很多关于这方面的问题，而且我知道这不是每个人都在考虑的事情，但对于那些正在考虑的人来说，你认为什么时候是与家庭成员彻底断绝联系的时候？我认为，我的意思是，默认情况下，你总是会给你的家庭成员，比如很多次机会。所以你心里其实已经有一本账，记录着你给这个人多少次机会了。然后，你知道的，因为，人们会尝试。好言相劝，他们会尝试尖叫，他们会尝试，你知道的，嘿，如果我们开始这样做
The last thing that I really want to focus on, because I get a lot of questions about this, and I know that it's not something that everyone is thinking about, but for those that are, when do you think it is time to go no contact with a family member? I think, I mean, by default, you're just always going to give your family members, like lots of chances. So you'll already have a track record in place of how many chances you've given this person. Then, you know, because, and people will try. to speak nicely, they'll try screaming, they'll try, you know, hey, if we start doing
你可能已经尝试过很多不同的方法了。你知道的，送礼物，你试过按照他们的方去做，你试过按照你自己的方式去做，你什么都试过了。通常当你准备好说“我必须离开”时，你已经用尽了许多选项。我认为当是时候彻底切断一段关系时，你可以，你总是可以为这段关系留一扇门，意思就是这些就是这段关系中存在的所有问题。再说一次，如果你愿意的话把它写下来，用信件的形式表达出来。再次强调，不管用什么方法，只要能把你的观点表达清楚，就去做。不要觉得必须当面说而感到压力。
the, you've probably already tried so many different ways. You know, gifts, you've tried doing it their way, you've tried doing it your way, you've just tried everything. Normally, when you're ready to be like, I've got to walk away, you've exhausted a lot of options. And I think that when it's time to pull the plug on a relationship, you can, you can always leave the door open in the sense of these have been all my problems with this relationship. And again, write it down if you prefer, do it in a letter. Again, whatever it takes to get your point across, do that. Don't feel the pressure if it has to be in person.
完全没必要。当我刚分手想跟我的前任谈谈时，我说，我们能见个面吗？我把要说的话写成便签，然后读给他听，因为我不想漏掉任何事情。但我想，我就是不想忘。因为我想，我知道如果我只是坐在那儿。如果需要这样做，那就去做。这根本不重要。
It doesn't. When I wanted to have a talk with my ex when we just broke up and I'm like, can we please meet up? I wrote notes down and read it out to him because I don't want to forget anything. But I'm like, I just don't want to forget. Because I'm like, I know that if I just sat there. So if it takes that, do that. It doesn't matter.
但这必须是一件你能做到的事。说出这些就是问题所在。这就是我要求改变的地方。而这就是没有发生的事情。我尝试过这样做。这条路我试过了，那条路我也试过了，就是行不通。我不再试图改变你了。你无法改变任何人。你无法改变他们的行为。所以这就是为什么，如果他们没有改变，而且你不需要说，我要走了。
But it's got to be something where you can. say these have been the issues. This is what I've requested for change. And this is what's not happened. I've tried doing it. This way I've tried doing it. That way it's just not happened. I'm not going to try and change you anymore. You can't change someone. You can't change their behavior. So then that's when if they don't, and you don't have to say, I'm leaving.
我要把你从我的生活中剔除。你不需要说出来，但你可以说，但这并不是，你知道的，然后你，皮球现在踢到他们那边去了。他们显然不会做出积极的回应，因为他们过去就没有这样做过。但至少你把话放那儿了。然后你，就这样，你断绝联系。我总是说，因为有些人讨厌这种事态的最终结果，他们讨厌这是一个最终的结局。这就是为什么人们很难下定决心彻底结束这段关系。
I'm cutting you out of my life. You don't have to say it, but you say, but this has not been, you know, and you just, the ball's now in their court. They're not going to respond positively, obviously, because they haven't in the past. But at least you've put it there. And then you, that's it, you go no contact. I always say, because some people hate the finality of it, they hate that it's this final thing. So that's why people struggle to pull the plug on the relationship.
但我总是说，如果你想要这段关系，这里，我已经把我的需求确切地列出来了。公式就在这里。如果你回来并满足了这些基本需求，我真心愿意再试一次。但就目前而言，不，我受够了。而且你一次又一次地向我证明了你无法改变。因此，为了让人群更能接受这个想法，你并不是说我要永远把你切断，一切都结束了。无论如何，再也没有下一次了。
But I always say, if you want a relationship, there's, I've given you exactly what I need. There's the formula. If you came back and just catered to these basic needs, I would genuinely be open to trying again. But as it stands, no, I'm done. And you've shown time and time again that you can't change. So to make people feel more open to the idea, you're not saying I'm cutting you out forever, it's done. Never again no matter what.
因为那样太，就像我说的，人们在生命中会经历如此多的演变。你知道的，我见过人们做出疯狂的调整。我见过一个母亲因为儿子是同性恋而把他赶出家门，她说，我无法接受，我无法接受，但在两年内，她在自己的Facebook上发布了他所有的，嗯，变装照片，配文说感到无比自豪，哦，天哪，多么美丽，人们所能做出的改变。因为她把他赶了出去，他选择了断绝联系，而她说：我简直失去了我的儿子。是的，这完全是我的决定，那是我的错，那是我的错。是的，所以不要抱有幻想，以为“哦，天哪，这将会引发改变”，绝对要做到零期待，因为你已经
Because that's so, like I said, people go through so many evolutions in their life. You know, I've seen people make crazy adjustments. I've seen a mom kick her son out because he was gay and she's like, I can't accept it, I can't accept it, to within two years posting all his, um, drag photos on her Facebook being like so proud oh my god how beautiful the change that people can make because she kicked him out and he went no contact and she's like i've literally lost my son yeah and it's completely my decision that was my fault that was my fault yeah so not not to get your hopes up thinking oh my god this is what's going to cause the change absolutely have zero expectations because you've
看到了过往记录，但只需说，听着，我受够了。我真的受够了目前这种关系。我永远受够了。如果你想建立一段新的关系，我绝对持开放态度。如果你想建立一段新的关系。是的。我其实真的很，这就像你并不是在试图修复旧关系。
seen the track record but just say look i'm done i'm actually done with this relationship as it stands I'm done forever. If you want to create a new one, I'd definitely be open to that. If you want to create a new one. Yeah. I actually really, it's like you're not trying to repair the old relationship.
它结束了。它完成了。它完成了。我受够了。是的。就像你已经达到了这个程度。达到了极限，我要走开。
It's done. It's finished. It's finished. I've had enough. Yeah. Like you've reached here. The limit, I'm walking away.
但话又说回来，就像我一直说的，人类生来就渴望连接。他们想要，你知道的，所以如果他们在五年后、两年后来找你并说：
But yeah, like I'm always, people innately want to connect. They want, you know, so you're likely to, if they were to come in five years time, two years time and say,
我搞砸了。我愿意，我想再试一次。我知道，你到底需要什么。你已经向我解释过了，我要试一试。你很可能会说，是的，我想。你知道的，天哪。我真的超爱这段话，对我来说，听完这些感觉相当深奥。哦，太好了。是的，谢谢你。谢谢你。那种感觉就像，哇，这，这是一个多么好的，我确实认为人们，哦，我讨厌说人们是善良的，但我认为人们更容易
I fucked up. I'm willing, I want to give it a shot. I know, exactly what it is that you need. You've explained it to me and I'm going to try. You're going to likely be like, yeah, I want to. Yeah. You know, geez. I actually loved, that was quite profound for me listening to that. Oh, good. Yeah, thank you. Thank you. Being like, wow, that's, that's such a good like, I do think that people, oh, I hate to say people are good, but I think it's easier for people
根据你向他们展示的你应得的对待方式，来为你做出正确的决定。我知道有时候这感觉像是一种沉重的负担，而且要说“我希望我的家人不需要我这样做，我不需要给他们一本指南”真的很难。这对很多人来说是悲伤的。这对人类的同理心来说是一种消耗。是的。我知道。这太难了。但这也是那种让你在这个时刻去决定这种负担是否值得，或者你是否不想去承担它的事情之一。这绝对只能由你自己来决定。我真的对此深信不疑。就像你，你真的必须为自己做出那个决定。这是一份优缺点列表
to make the right decisions by you when you show them how you deserve to be treated. And I know it feels like such a burden sometimes and it is really hard to be like I I wish I had family members where I didn't have to do this where I didn't have to give them like a guidebook. It's sad for a lot of people. It's hard. On human empathy. Yeah. I know. That's so difficult. But it's also one of those things where you get to decide at this moment whether that burden is worth it or whether you don't want to take it on. And that is like only a decision that you can make. I really think that quite deeply. Like you, you really have to make that decision for yourself. And it is a pros and cons list
我确信它是广泛的、复杂的、微妙的。但这确实需要时间。我想希望这一集能为你提供正确的工具，让你知道如何去做，知道如何到达那个你认为必须采取激进措施的地步。而且，当你最终做出决定并拍板时，这确实赋予了你力量。因为很多身处这些极具操控性关系中的人
that I'm sure is extensive and complex and nuanced. But it does take time. And I think that hopefully this episode is like given you the right equipment to know how to do that and know how to get to that point where you do think that drastic measures need to be taken. And it's very, it is empowering when you do finally come to a decision and make that decision. Because a lot of people that are in these really manipulative relationships
他们自身与自己的关系也存在问题，特别是如果你是在那种环境中长大的话。所以，当你在那种环境中呆了那么久之后，要做出这样的决定并将自己放在第一位，可能真的很不容易。正如我常说的，如果一个人是在一个美丽、快乐的家庭、快乐的家庭中长大，很容易就会觉得，哦，管他呢，谁在乎呢，去他的吧。但事实是，不，你是在那种环境中长大的。
have issues with their own relationship with themselves, especially if you were raised in that environment. So it's probably really hard to make a call like that and put yourself first when you've been around that environment for so long. And like I always say, if someone's been grown up in this beautiful, happy family, happy family, it's easy to look and say, oh, just like, who gives a fuck, who cares, yeah. But it's like, no, you've raised in that environment.
所以，对你来说，哪怕只是做出那个决定或做出改变，都需要付出巨大的努力。而且我认为这实际上将是你真正、真正建立自我关系的第一步。你知道的，你必须，就像，你教会别人如何对待你。我坚信这一点。你必须教会别人如何对待你。如果这意味着走开并说，我再也不能这样做了，这是一个重大的表态。
So for you to even make that call or to make the change, it takes a lot. And I think it will actually be your first step into really, really building on your relationship with yourself. You know, it's, you've got to, like, you teach people how to treat you. I totally believe that. You have to teach people how to treat you. And if it means walking away and saying, I cannot do this anymore, that's a huge statement.
但你必须将它贯彻到底，因为那样的话，你知道的，如果你，你知道的，这并不是说，我已经永远把你从我的生活中切断了，就像我们刚才谈到的那样，但它确实是在说，我再也不能这样折磨自己了。是的。其实，圣诞节/假期，正是做这件事的大好时机。错过一个大型家庭节日并不意味着你把自已从他们的生活中切断了，但它确实传递了一个相当明确的信息。它传递了一个非常明确的信息。
But you have to follow through with it because then, you know, if you, you know, it's not to say, I've cut you out forever like we just spoke about, but it is saying, I cannot do this to myself anymore. Yeah. Actually, Christmas slash holidays, great time to do it. Missing a big family holiday doesn't mean that you've cut your, self out of their life, but it does send a pretty clear message. It sends a very clear message.
不是永久的，但也非常有力量。非常有力。我认为这是一个……而且它并不具有攻击性。它不具有攻击性。这只是你的缺席。你的缺席，有时无声胜有声。不做任何回应本身也是一种回应。
Not permanent, but also very powerful. Very. I think that this is a... And it's not aggressive. It's not aggressive. It's just your absence. It's your absence and your absence speaks louder than words sometimes. No response is also a response.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧度、健康水平以及建立恢复力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家进行对话，
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts,
以及更多人，以此超越那些在健康产业中占据主导地位的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为植物油本质上具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是在I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO%”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）莉尔·金（Lil Kim）的胸部吗？
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克（Sam Jek）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集中，我们都会挑选一个时刻，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过这段经历的。包括最近一集里马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代的快克（可卡因）。
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s.
坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊当年的快克，不过为了让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Games）。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark），有时我们在追求某事时，会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark, Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
而我们却仍在追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算做够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要。你是一个好人，仅仅是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
而那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她故事中前后矛盾的明显破绽。这就开启了一场历时多年的法庭之战，旨在证明真相。你在这份特定的测试上作假了两次，太多了。我只作假了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle, prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的天哪，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。非常感谢你能来。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Grega lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Thank you so much for coming on.
我觉得这是一场非常重要的讨论，尤其是在这个时候。显而易见，我想我可以代表我们两人向你们倾注满满的爱、力量、同理心和同情心，理解你们在这个时期不得不经历这段经历。我知道看到那些看似没有任何问题的极度幸福家庭可能会让人感到艰难。每个家庭都有他们的问题。我发自内心地这么说，而且你们已经做得非常棒了。是的。是的。
I feel like that was such an important discussion to be having around this time. obviously I think I can speak from both of us like sending a lot of love and strength and empathy to you guys and sympathy that you are having to go through this experience around this time. I know it can be hard seeing really happy families who seem to have no problems. Every family has their problems. I will say that from the bottom of my heart and you are doing an amazing job. Yeah. Yeah.
绝对不孤单。他们能在哪里找到你？如果他们还不知道你是谁，首先这太离谱了，但他们到底在哪里可以找到你？所以这个播客叫做《Do You Fucking Mind?》或者就像它拼写的那样，Do You F星号，星号，星号，M。它的封面是一个橙色的艺术作品，上面有内容和我。
Definitely not alone. Where can they find you? If they do not know who you are already, firstly ridiculous, but where can they find you? So the podcast is called Do You Fucking Mind? Or like it's spelt do you F asterix, asterix, asterisk, M. M. And it's like an orange artwork with the content and me.
我会把它放在简介里。亚历克西斯（Alexis），非常感谢你来做客。像往常一样，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时留下五星好评。无论你现在在哪里收听，如果你有任何关于节目的建议，或者有什么我们还没谈到、但你很想听我们聊聊的话题，
I'll put it in the description. Alexis, thank you so much for coming on. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review. Wherever you are listening right now, if you have an episode suggestion, something that we haven't spoken about that you would love to hear from us.
请关注我的Instagram账号：That Psychology Podcast，你可以在那里给我们发私信。希望你喜欢这一集。像往常一样，我们下周会带着新的一集回归。祝你度过一个愉快的周末。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Games）为您带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本无法安全进行的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披一副铠甲？
please follow me at That Psychology Podcast and you can send us a DM over there. I hope you enjoyed this episode. As always, we will be back next week with another one. Have a great weekend. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
它向世界释放出的信号是：你可不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你拥有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你在这份特定的测试上作假了两次，对吗？我只作假了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的天哪，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网难逃》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他您获取播客的平台上收听《Love Trapped》。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立抗挫力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover
让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他您获取播客的平台上收听 TWO%。当一群女性发现
they've all dated the same prolific con artist, They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
她们约会的竟然是同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。
On the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他您获取播客的平台上收听。这是一档 iHeart 播客。真人保证。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。